hey don't man hey we're not you we were
saying that you were John Rocker to that
story yeah so don't worry about that
yeah Rory call going nice to meet you as
has entered what's going on me and how
are you good thank you very much we we
never think anyone's ever heard of us
yeah so Helen lacell last night yes I
was gonna so yeah we was actually I was
on I was going through all your stuff on
Google last night now it's like oh yeah
because I knew you from movies did you
see a new movie we didn't see the new
why would you start that's just a bad
way to start a new because you can tell
us about the movie so I don't I don't I
don't have to do it a destroy you cannot
plug in but you could have waited five
minutes or just leading to it like oh
like what was your favorite scene not
like just say hey by the way you
interrupted me I apologize you just
announce the I figured you were gonna
say that
maybe you saw I just didn't I can only
be honest or worried I don't think
anyone's seen it Friday thank you there
yeah that's right no but I was why today
he mentioned Hell in a Cell last night
and I was going through and I've
forgotten that I saw your brother at
WrestleMania at Radio ROK's he's doing
his podcast next to me and like
everything came back to me because he
was like yeah my brother Macaulay Culkin
okay because he was like my brother I
think it was you were getting married
the next day on the Saturday and he was
like Paul Heyman's gonna do his wedding
and at the time I was like that's
amazing and then I didn't realize till
last night that you were the brother who
got married by Paul Heyman's my rabbi
which is I mean it was amazing he
started doing very cool but he started
doing full-on wrestling schtick oh he
was threatening my family in the
audience it was fantastic you like that
that's what you wanted at him yeah I had
like a brief talk with him beforehand
and I was like don't be afraid to be
mean to my family and he really took
that note and yeah was he meaner than
you thought he'd be it was perfect I
mean he's a he's a he'll you know okay
and he brought a cameraman with him to
film it and my clothes no yeah yeah um
and we didn't know but then bits of our
wedding are now on on the internet oh
you did not give that was not part of
the plan right but I was sort of angry
about it for like a night
then I realized we just got screwed by
like the biggest heel in WWE kind of an
honor yeah that's what he should do yeah
somebody's gonna if somebody's gonna
Kearney you out of your wedding film it
should be him Yeah right
how are you merit your young guy since
WrestleMania so since April ok yeah do
you like it I enjoy it yeah I'm enjoying
it I feel more adult you do right I
guess is your wife a fan of Paul Heyman
yes she's a big red she's arresting I'm
more into like UFC yeah
but she's really into that so now I'm
I'm into that as well cuz they just
uhand did she tolerate your stuff and
you tolerate hers like I will watch this
tonight and watch that tomorrow yeah she
used to be the UFC and then it sort of
fell off he's had enough enough blood
okay yeah cuz as you watch it I'm like
Paul Heyman is making this guy's wedding
completely about himself
yeah like poem if you look it up but
Troy you could play it for for Norton
these pick up Rory Culkin wedding my
buddies host this podcast called we
watch wrestling mm-hmm it's a very good
wrestling podcast but they take me to
shows a lot like bar wrestling and stuff
like that in LA but they but they're
they've talked about your brother
they've been like Macaulay Culkin pops
up with these things a lot more like he
interviews like Chris Jericho and all
that yeah yeah yeah those are fun shows
there's bar wrestling shows
I haven't they wrestle some of them
don't even have rings and they'll
wrestle literally just through oh it's
the bar it's it's [ __ ] on and they
and then give you a warning before the
show they go if two wrestles are coming
at you and they see the move [ __ ]
move like they're not kidding get out of
the way but it's it's it's really fun
man what kind of show is that thing I
know what's happening
like right now I'm listening yeah it's
just like I don't know what you're
talking about wrestling and they have a
wrestling event you know ball I thought
and everybody's just drinking and it's
[ __ ] wild wrestling I thought so fun
but you know what I'm glad that you said
that because the fact that you said that
I would imagine most of the audience is
like what the [ __ ] I want to you know be
an idiot but I know they have footage of
your wedding on TMZ sports yes if you
didn't realize they didn't realize that
was because you're not like a TMZ yeah
30 people at my wedding it was tiny
this is a small intimate private affair
yeah right here on TMZ on TMZ
[Applause]
he's doing his wrestling carrots while
you're holding hands waiting to continue
your lives
did you was there was there in that
moment were you like I can't cuz I was
watching it and I'm like I'm assuming
he's gonna twist this and mention you
guys but he just did the Brock Lesnar
yeah no it's all about bro how long did
he how long did he actually how long did
the ceremony take with him it was at
least five minute promo he was cutting
any he kept talking about the main event
tomorrow night at WrestleMania so he was
trying to sell WrestleMania to the 30
people in the audience yeah exactly
we all we're all sold already did he
talk to you talk about you guys at all
no I mean I only met him like an hour
before I thought he was gonna bail
was he allowed to do this as you
ordained yeah he got he got ordained for
us on our license I think it's he's a
shot he's our shaman he you know why he
did this like when you were like I
thought he's gonna bail but then he was
like wait putting a camera guy and I can
put it on my youtube channel well that's
right plugging WrestleMania yeah I'm
leaking this later so it'll be good Jim
you're a show business guy do you think
that Paul Heyman gave this footage to
TMZ on the house no I don't think I
believe that Paul Paul Heyman uh
profited from your most amazing and
special day that's not TMZ sports I
never well yeah I mean he also probably
us to do these now for money so yeah
also cutting a commercial for himself
that's a hundred percent arrow at WWE
can't be like we don't want you doing
this cuz he's like look I'm like like
I'm plugging WrestleMania more than Rory
forwards winning and this is your wife
is giving her vows exactly and luckily
it cut off before she really gets into
it but because those are deeply personal
yeah the woman that you love in your
life with let's see what happen yeah
let's do it
to marry you on this rainy day in New
Orleans on the
[Laughter]
you hear that puff cuz he he interrupted
the vows to get his [ __ ] in that was a
vas move right there really was yeah
yeah he's like you guys weren't like was
there any like because you're not like
as big of a wrestling fan as she is was
there a part of you that was like I mean
I I know that this is cool that you're
here but you can't interrupt the vows me
and no I loved it I was just worried
that she would maybe be you know but she
was into it and yeah it was it was an
owner you know my my wife's not a not a
wrestling fan obviously I am I would
totally do this exact same thing my wife
would be furious
it just made it about himself yeah she'd
be mad so do you train at all or no no
no you just watch Archer
yeah I mean then not seriously no yeah
yes she'd be pissed yeah did you not
watch like he'll miss out with you know
what she watch me she'll like fall
asleep like she was we were doing gyms
live shows on Friday and Saturday this
weekend and somebody she overheard in a
conversation as having with somebody
that Helena Sal was on Sunday she's like
wait so you're gone Friday and Saturday
and Sunday is a wrestling night and
that's like yeah and Monday and Tuesday
as well this is what you you married
into this yes I signed up for this yeah
garbage even the [ __ ] Liotta speech
what I'm kidding I love wrestling I mean
you being a fan is in danger how did
your wife I met her on a on a set I did
a movie called scream four years ago and
she was she's in the camera department
she's a camera system that's cool yeah
how did when you did scream for cuz
you've done a lot of like independent
movies but I feel like scream for and
signs when you were like a little kid or
I probably like the to really like
massive movies and scream for being a
franchise was there different pressure
like on opening weekend and things like
that or does that not really affect you
yeah I mean it's just a way bigger like
carpet and and you know a lot of the
e-news and
and things like that which I don't know
but a lot of cooks in the kitchen I
guess when it's a bigger do you like all
the attention like do you like the fame
part of it no I mean I guess it's part
of the job right no but for you it's
just actually the job yeah I really
enjoy working and I like you know
talking to you guys that's that's cool
right but you know enews and stuff did
you want this is what you wanted to do
or you just did it because of what your
uh you know your family you mean you
mean acting yeah yeah I mean I guess I
sort of grew up on a on a set and my
first movie it was nine and but you know
I have other siblings that sort of
bailed out early and we were all given
the opportunity to bail if we'd like
what are the other what are the ones who
bailed out doing well well there's seven
of us so I could go down the list but
there's you know a chef there's a writer
three three pretty successful actors
Thanks so you know I mean that's that's
a lot for one family yeah yeah that's uh
that out beats that you guys beat up the
Baldwin's yeah sure the dogs up in one
thing that was kind of a wrap it all
fell off at the Kirk and Michael people
have to they usually do well with two
and number three was it fun doing um
Castle work yeah yeah yeah that was I
would watch it oh cool yeah I mean it's
hard to it was hard to follow filming it
like being a guest on a show is way
different than being a sure regular cuz
you sort of don't know what's going on
and you're learning as you go but um
yeah I was gonna ask you how like see I
mean you must have been signing
non-disclosure is out the ass like I
feel like there was so probably so much
secrets why it was it was an anthology
sort of mystery show based on the
Stephen King universe and it's just like
I there's no [ __ ] way anybody was
stepping onto that set without having to
sign Oh it's also a bad robot which did
you know they do Star Wars now in the
last and everything so they're pretty
secretive thing oh yeah lost held out
pretty good on the on what it really is
happening they kept their theme I mean a
secret oh yeah yeah I guess they're used
to that yeah yeah I mean I mean JJ
Abrams like kept Cloverfield the whole
movie was a secret until it came out
like he please he still pulls that off
some of that last Cloverfield but again
was a secret nobody even knows me May
yeah like he pulls that [ __ ] off somehow
man yeah they called somebody else while
they're making it what they did like
they definitely when they were filming
Cloverfield like in New York it was some
weird I don't remember what the title
was but it was some completely different
title called come town come town a weird
weird turn the no but you played a
really cool part on Castle Rock where
he's not I mean it's it's already out
I'm not spoiling anything but he like I
don't know if you guys lived in the
woods or what but he like kind of lives
out in the woods with this guy who
basically cut his voice box out so he
can't speak he can only hear and he's
and he's like his interpreter when he
signs and it's a real weird freaky kind
of in the forest listening for the voice
of God yeah yeah
is that why sparks out yeah yeah why
couldn't you just not talk to us because
I mean it heightens his uh is he uh
eerie that went in creepiest part is
when he when he goes and I think you
translate the line when he goes no I
made myself better yeah whatever
whatever the line is yeah George doing
fake sign language on the radio just
putting his hands in front of his throat
and making like he's talking somebody's
not and then and then ending his
statements without question marks Aurora
sitting there like yep did you grow up
like a fan of movies cuz you know you
had a pretty amazing insight in the
sense that like you knew how they were
made
from the time you were born pretty much
right yeah I think the magics still
there is it yeah sure yeah so where did
you grow up a fan of um well I don't
want to sound like a I don't know
snooty but I'm a big like Stanley
Kubrick guy yeah and yeah what's your
top 11 favorite 11 and go up
that's why Castle Rock was a big deal
for me because the shining connections
yeah yeah and I like that little spoiler
alert if you haven't seen it but I like
that little button at the end with
Shelley Duvall dr. Phil the dr. Phil
show Duvall interviewed it turns up at
the know there's a there's a
that the next season might be shining
related with a character named Jackie
Torrance who's the niece of Jack
Torrance she's a niece yes
that's amazing her name's Jackie
Torrance because she's a girl
Oh perfect yeah you get it worked out
nicely kind of like in [ __ ] Wall
Street when they do the return 20 years
later and they [ __ ] Rudy this dead
girl back so that someone can get
involved what I thought it was the son
yes that's dead we got a daughter yeah
but we're supposed to believe there's
somebody on Wall Street at the jail for
20 years you don't think Michael Douglas
had the connections to get out earlier
after 20 not the insider trading I'll do
you in for 20 years I like the second
Wall Street I did too except for the
fact they killed off Rudy or having died
who's Rudy the sign Huxtable Rudy yes
Rudy Huxtable I'm sorry in every street
he had a son yeah he did yes ma'am Rudy
would pick his second wall street you
don't even know what happened and they
made him a daughter I watched them Star
Wars style I went back to the first one
is a free for Rudy he's throwing stuff
and he hits the lawyer in the face
lawyer has to laugh he's not happy about
it why wouldn't they just make Shia
LaBeouf a grown-up Rudy who has to
reconnect with his father because that
pie would have been good no you know
what I loved it that you did Rory the
Waco series oh thank you I watched the
whole thing were you like are you a true
crime person before that or did you end
up going like oh this is interesting let
me read a whole bunch about this yeah
I'm pretty pretty into that stuff so
when that came up you're like this is
gonna be a really interesting story to
tell I don't know fun is how many
parties was it I think I saw this like
eight six six yet six yeah yeah and you
were one of the few people that survived
your character was one of the few people
that survived the whole thing yeah so
you actually get to talk to him yeah he
was on set the whole time that's amazing
[ __ ] it was intimidating in the
beginning because I just felt like he
was staring at me and thinking I'm
blowing it you know yeah it's where when
you're playing someone they're watching
you yeah what am i weird if it was
Koresh I was actually wrong by the way
his Ruby Ridge was the thing I watched
okay it was the thing that kind of
sparked yeah and did they make a show
they did yeah I don't remember what it
was either killed in the cabin where the
definitely saw you
they definitely did yeah I think yeah
he's the same sniper that was shooting
at Ruby Ridge was also at Waco oh really
connection yeah yeah this was where like
they kill his with his wife or son or
something yeah Gary
LF you try something it's in Waco it's
in the first episode they show a bit of
Ruby Ridge yeah I'm sorry
yeah so what was the Waco show I didn't
is about Waco is what David Koresh for
instance I put that so what do you ask
what place Jana and I'll see it go Waco
which channel is it on they run in Will
Ferrell and ahead and do the SNL
character what was this perspective like
like what was it like talking to a guy
as he as he kind of is it kind of nuts
because he lived through that is he
processed it completely a surprisingly
normal and he sort of laughs about it
all really and and he says that like if
he's not laughing he's gonna start
crying so yeah his family killed no it
was just him he was he was 22 there and
he hadn't been there very long everyone
was there for their whole lives and
how'd he get out how did he get out yeah
he busted through a window during the
fire and yeah was Koresh keeping people
there to make them die or is it just the
way it happened apparently he allowed he
had the door open and you could leave if
he wanted to but but he had like
brainwashed people and they really
believed he was Jesus right I thought he
was the second coming of Jesus yeah
which you know you tend to trust that
guy right yeah it's a it's a delicate
thing I've been watching my words with
it especially because I've been around
now you're represent yeah yeah now did
it real like the character you're
playing when you met the guy did it feel
like he thought that he had been
brainwashed a little bit or because he
was only there for a little bit of time
he kind of had a proper perspective on
you sort of one one foot in one foot out
so any you know he preface is everything
with I know it sounds crazy but right
but the things he told me and the things
he would you had to meet him to
understand and we will never get that
opportunity how long all correction
correct oh yeah yeah yeah is he was a
charismatic guy some people just have an
ability to to [ __ ] they're just
Cara's my
I mean he pretty but I think he believed
that himself maybe that's like when you
watch the Scientology documentaries and
the people are like how did why did you
do this and they're like you never met
David Miscavige you this guy [ __ ]
talks to you and it's you don't
understand some people just quit being
motivational and maybe I and Miscavige
could probably convince anybody to join
Scientology because he's if you can run
that organization you're a charismatic
guy mm-hmm yeah my character in Waco we
don't cover this in the series but he
was really interested in aliens and he
would he kept asking David Koresh about
aliens and crush would sort of give him
a knowing nod and be like someday I'll
tell you all about it and kept stringing
along like there's something there and
I'll let you know and he never he never
got to and that's the other thing he
probably feels a little bit lost he
probably feels like I know that there's
something out there some any feels like
oh this might be the thing that I've
been looking for him finally gonna know
the truth did I
does he know now the Koresh had no
information for him no he still thinks
he might have had some information I
think so on some level he kind of still
what was interesting we had the FBI
negotiator was also on set so the guy
that was on the other side talking to
Koresh the whole time yeah so we had
both sides of the you know on sitting
next to each other that's very great the
FBI agents say about him what did you
not talk to him yeah I spoke to him a
lot he I'm sort of like Koresh could
have prevented all this and you know
sort of like damn it David how do you
let this happen
and everyone's like damn it Gary how did
you let this happen right what was the
name of the character you played David
Thibodeau Thibodeau that was it did he
to this day does he kind of think that
David wasn't the villain here that this
was what the FBI did I I don't know I
sort of see it as like a villain was the
leader of all of these good people and
then right FBI sort of seemed villainous
but there was this good person leading
them and then they were trying to sort
of work it out and yeah right so all
these kind of good people get lumped in
yeah with stuff that this guy did
because everybody was there for the
right intentions yeah and there's no
there's no way to justify it you know
people you know you talk about wake on
they're like yeah but Koresh was you
know touching young girls mmm-hmm but
does that mean you should burn the young
girl's alive because the girls are dead
now that you can't justify that Janet
Reno just attack
yeah yeah it's very conscious days very
controversy I mean even talking about
when the show was on I remember talking
about it and like immediately college
we're calling up being like don't
believe this side's [ __ ] don't
believe that side's [ __ ] here's what
really heavy one knows what really
happened but nobody really knows what
happened exactly yeah exactly
Wow it's pretty amazing